[Music]
we begin with breaking news uh in
kyrgyzstan the prime minister
has resigned now this comes straight
after the election commission
annulled the early results of sunday's
votes
and the speaker of the parliament has
also resigned now this comes after a
night of violence where protesters
stormed
state buildings now they're accusing the
government of
rigging the election in its favor
the protesters freed former president
al-masbaq
and other senior officials from jail
president asuran bay
jinbikov has insisted that he is still
in control
of the country well charles stratfords
is on the line from the capital bishkek
to bring us the very latest charles
we've now had a dramatic resignation now
what more can you tell us
yes and more news on the back on the
back of those resignations we
have heard in the last hour or so that
um
since then uh parliament session was
indeed held in that hotel it had been
scheduled to be held earlier in the day
and we've been
expecting it to have been delayed until
tomorrow
sounds very much as if the session was
hurried through
we know that in order for any votes to
be um
to be valid there had to be 61 members
of parliament
that's a majority of one of 120
members had to be there to make unique
votes we understand that only 20 members
made it to the hotel we uh i believe
that's because of security concerns
the others they voted with a letter of
of an attorney a letter of attorney but
on the basis of that vote
we now have a new parliament speaker
and a new prime minister in kyrgyzstan
the parliament speaker is a man called
mikhtebek abdul daif
um who was uh has been a member of
parliament for 10 years or so he's
widely believed to have been
pro government throughout that period um
more interestingly arguably is the uh
is the appointment of a man called
japarov who is the new
prime minister now when we were standing
outside the parliamentary buildings this
morning
watching the opposition supporters
celebrating having taken control of that
last night
chaparral arrived he had been freed from
jail
by opposition supporters he was
serving an eleven and a half year jail
term for kidnapping
they freed him from jail he was welcomed
with with
uh jubilation there was big celebrations
um outside of the parliament building
we understand according to sources um
who
saw this parliamentary session that
japan actually threatened
members of parliament by saying that uh
if
if they didn't make him or vote him into
uh the vote him as
the new prime minister then he had
thousands of supporters that would come
to support him
and possibly cause trouble so it's it's
another indication that it
shows just how chaotic the last 48 hours
have been
and of course it draws in more questions
of the legitimacy
of any kind of leadership in this
country going forward after these
elections
um you know there's enough distrust
anyway with with the parliament
following these elections that have been
now being annulled
um and now it seems as if members of
parliament indeed the prime minister
this man japan who has a criminal record
or indeed was a servant serving a jail
term is now being
given a very powerful position in this
country
again it throws great doubt great
questions over
the future stability uh or the stability
of kyrgyzstan tonight um and
in the days ahead it certainly is a very
uh fast-moving situation there uh
charles stratford
thank you very much indeed for bringing
us the latest on the political turmoil
in kyrgyzstan